oh that's how i got the engine to work
[Music]
these primitive elements go into
creating a working primitive engine that
allows me to power my zombie escape
vehicle this might be one of the most
intimidating vfx shots i've ever worked
on it took me about 25 hours to complete
how do we build a primitive combustion
engine start with a log chop both sides
of the log off you take four cylinders
of bamboo and jam them into the log like
a v-twin engine smack on the uh
the
the
crankshaft basically the thing that
turns all of the basically the things
that allows all of the to pump properly
guys i did i did like 20 minutes of
engine research to figure this out bear
with me on the terminology so after you
have the crankshaft in which is just a
flattened piece of bamboo that splays
out like this i fix the exhaust pipe on
and then i start throwing in black
powder into each one of the bamboo
cylinders and then i chuck these
crystals in and every time i chuck a
crystal into one of the bamboo cylinders
a little explosion comes out so once i
throw in the last explosive crystal the
engine starts black smoke starts
shooting out from the exhaust pipe and
every step that i just mentioned is its
own visual effects element and visual
effects challenge in one shot just a lot
of rotoscoping it's a lot of work it's a
lot of tracking it's a lot of everything
hence you know the three three or so
days of of work on this one shot let's
let's just talk about like step by step
going back to the top i'm using a rock
to smash this bamboo piece into like a
radial gear type crankshaft and that's
just a jump cut in camera so i need to
smooth that out extended the heads of it
back just a little bit so it gave me
like three extra frames to work with and
i rode my hand for that chunk that just
helps smooth out that jump cut and we're
out hammering in
bamboo cylinders into this log here the
two holes on the top let's cover those
bad boys up that exhaust is covered up
with a clean plate of another log we
shot just sitting there with the light
and the leaves bouncing around the
shadows going all crazy and then i hit
it with the hammer and it goes straight
in and at this point so here here's the
thing here's what here's what's tough is
i have to get out of this clean plate
world because if i don't i'm screwed so
what i need to do is figure out a way to
transition from the clean plate to the
real footage and there's quite a
difference between the two this is this
is my real shadow on the real
log i'm interacting with how am i going
to blend that and wren came up with a
great idea so anytime my shadow crosses
over the log it's painting on the real
footage if you look at the shadow here
it's cutting from the clean plate
to
the original shadow allowing me to get
out of this clean plate i test it and i
flick the crankshaft it starts spinning
i need these bamboo valves to move up
and down when the crankshaft spins i
copy the original bamboo i move it up
revealing new bamboo
that isn't there i have to create that i
go into photoshop use content where
extend the existing bamboo to give me
more bamboo to play with and then i roto
out real log to sit right on top of that
so it looks like they're going in and
out of the actual engine i have to do
that to every single one of these pieces
of bamboo
individually the clean plate has been
completely wiped away the top of the log
is completely real those cylinders are
completely real the only thing that's in
effect right now is this clean plate
covering the hole where the exhaust pipe
will go so that just helps me minimize
like all the stuff i'm doing at one time
in the shot
i'm just focusing on one thing now and
that is covering up this exhaust pipe
hole basically what's gonna happen now
is i come around to the other side of
the engine and i put this exhaust pipe
magically into the log
rotoscoping this exhaust pipe revealing
the original hole as i place it in what
happens after that well i have to blend
this janky cut this janky cut right here
i gotta fix that
what i do is just isolate different
parts of the image extend them and
slowly fade them in to
the b point the b cut right there's a
number of layers going into this you
just have duplicated versions of the
take seconds before it cuts over top and
slowly blended them in over time and
then when it cuts it's already there
it's already
it's what i faded into yeah just to hide
one cut guys we've done it we're almost
there we've made it past the jump cut
that's the jump cut we're past the jump
cut like we have plates of firecrackers
going off in these little bamboo
cylinders comping those
over top pretty easy stuff physical
appearance of the bamboo pipes have
changed because of the black powder or
the smoke i have to roto out the top
hole but it's doable oh but what's this
over here is this jake's hand you gotta
fade into that clean plate you know what
i'm saying jake is out i have to get
this thing cranking again so once jake
pulls the exhaust pipe in the tank
that's basically the cue for the whole
engine is working now so i have to go
back and once again cut out each one of
these pipes move them up and down create
new pipe offset the movement so they're
all pumping at different times and then
i sit back and hit render for about an
hour and a half
and i still got little things i got to
fix so i'm not going to get into that
stuff but
that's how i got the engine to work bet
you weren't expecting this shot
i bet you weren't expecting a sword
fight
welcome to a special tournament of
champions here at corridor digital where
we fight for the wild card that's right
all of the losers of the previous three
rounds myself christian and ren are
going to be fighting in a three-man
single winner free-for-all to represent
lady patreon in the final tournament of
champions at the spring festival if
you're a patron or you sign up because
of this video leave a comment guys
because one person from patreon is gonna
get the top tier reward which is a one
on one with anyone from the studio for
an hour
for free whoever wins this one is gonna
be the representative of the people this
is a man in a crown
[Music]
[Music]
yo patreon is the best way to support
what we do here at corridor so if you
guys are interested in just showing a
little love head on over to patreon.com
quarter digital every dollar helps guys
we can buy more swords
yes masa
yeah
look
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the five dollars here because that gets
you a live stream with us we just hang
out for an entire hour this is a monthly
group hangout where everyone kind of
crowds around a computer we all read the
comments and respond to your questions
in real time because it's live streamed
it's fun i look forward to it every
month
did you know
you can hear your name or even see your
name on the core or crew channel if you
subscribe to one of the tiers where you
get a shout out so go to the patreon
page patreon.com corridor digital all
right guys
everyone's got a point this is what it
comes down to whoever gets this point
wins it all
what
come on
wait i have the opportunity now
to not only represent lady patreon but
to win back my battle axe
so there are some names of some patrons
that i'm gonna say as a thank you for
supporting us on this channel but first
i can't say your name until i've caught
a nut in my mouth
master one ace one
philip oxford
seth the mad scientist
astro gg
raymond abad
caleb gallant
reneo guerrero jr
elon almanza
hendrick lice
eddie adolf
ah
will robertson
gary dolph
nicholas saltos
[Music]
not a canadian spy
mitch plowinski
andrew double d avancino
glitch cube
timothy thompson
james bailey
almond alzabie
the idea is
showing you
actually
scavenging something yeah like
what it could be anything this was
supposed to say that fast zombies
chasing you makes it hard to scavenge
but the bars we don't get that scavenge
element in this shot yeah
we discussed a new opening yeah yeah oh
god it just seems like that's the
the best idea it really helped clarify
that uh you have to shoot that or like
just big big picture overall i think
it's great um i really enjoyed it it
still needs some sort of scene to finish
it off i don't think we need insert
shots i think we need to restructure it
and i think it'll make sense you do this
and then you just
you cut to
this yeah like he's going back going
back on the bike
oh my god coming back to get his gear
yeah
this is because now it's like whoa
because now we're interested in what's
gonna happen next
we're gonna leave the cam hard cut like
what is going on why is he driving
around there
this is way funnier
that works it's funny oh of course
that's where the crystals are hilarious
okay well yeah we're good okay cool i'm
fine
boys
yeah it's pretty sick all right
yeah did you say you built this wall i
did i i remember
back in 1981 being on a very tall ladder
carrying up the pieces of sheetrock
putting it up there and and holding it
into the studs and
yeah i built this whole wall i built
this wall
everything i built all these walls so
when you got this whole building was it
just one china one giant space imagine a
space next door but connected to this
and this was open
this was amazing this this under the
mezzanine this is over the mezzanine
where nico's
that was it was all open you could walk
from
here
all the way over on that mezzanine all
the way down to the end of brandon's
space
and
there were these giant machines
six foot
in diameter
eight feet high about eight feet high
giant stainless steel revolving drums
with a with a catwalk around each one
and they were mixing you know what they
were mixing was it paint pigment not not
not known
yes they were mixing pigment
pigment pigment pigment
powder powder right paint powder because
people didn't used to buy
pre-mixed gallons of paint
when you bought paint back in the day in
the 20s 30s and 40s you bought a box of
pigment and a can of base and you went
home and you mixed it yourself
whoa
yeah i mean it's it's not until the
late 50s early 60s that you could go to
a hardware store and go hey give me a
can of uh
lime green paint and it would be already
mixed or ready to go now you bought a
you bought your own box of pigment this
was the company that made the powdered
pigment and you would open it up and put
the pigment in your one gallon of paint
and then mix it up with a stirring rod
so
when we bought this place when we came
here to look at it to buy it
there were 10 of these giant stainless
steel machines going
spinning around like a centrifuge
and and with an inside was a like a
blade that looked like a waffle iron
mixing the powder so when you ended up
buying the place did you inherit those
drums as well or
so they took that out and they left it
pretty much the way it was so we just
had to build all of these walls and
divide it up
okay see you
dude steve's always got the best stories
i love when he rolls around spewing
knowledge and experience and i'm just
like okay
this is the third time in a little over
a day my computer is forced to restart
and update
and it just sits here for like an hour
i'm not even kidding
trying to make a star wars video